yeah that's the most like yeah yeah i
you know i got rid of like
twitter facebook um all i have is
instagram
youtube yeah cause i mean instagram is a
little bit more
controllable yeah yeah but like i was
like this
like twitter i just see [ __ ] that i go i
don't even follow this
i was like i don't even know why it pops
up it just [ __ ] this like
pops up that i don't even like follow so
i'm like how the [ __ ] did that happen
so i was like i gotta get off of that
and it's just too much of that it's just
you know not good yeah yeah it doesn't
let you like
you know i mean you can get like i don't
think it's bad
but it can be yeah you know what i mean
it's like
it's like alcohol like for me yeah it's
bad for me
yeah yeah you know dude social dilemma
documentary
no i heard about it holy [ __ ] dude it's
really good it's freaky
yeah i came across yeah everyone's
literally the same reaction
everything you're talking i mean it's
what you're talking about it's just like
how
the tech industries have just like lost
control of trying to make more money
more
ad revenue by just keeping people
engaged and feeding him the [ __ ] that
they like
think about anything that [ __ ]
happens um
covet you know these [ __ ] things
capitalize off of that
mm-hmm you know um you know
[ __ ] with racial injustice capitalize
off of that all these
all these things that like these big
things
that you know that the way they and they
the way they push this information
the [ __ ] politics yeah everything you
know what i mean i
i like you're 33 right yeah how old are
you 32
32. so i remember growing up
you know i didn't i never knew anyone to
[ __ ] argue
or care if they were democrat or
republican
right yeah that was never like a thing i
don't remember that ever being a thing
until more so recently
right and it's the weirdest [ __ ] to me
and it's like
you know first of all i think anyone's
crazy that just [ __ ]
devotes himself to one [ __ ] insider
this is the weirdest [ __ ] to me because
like you like
you're not giving anything else a chance
exactly you know what i mean
and and that's the thing that's like
that's why i love
like mark twain has this quote about
like travel
you know like going every like yeah
about staying in a small pocket yeah
and how you know that doesn't [ __ ]
help you do
like if you just stay on this side you
stay right here yeah
like your brain you're you're not you're
disrespecting your [ __ ] brain right
you know what i mean and that's exactly
there that's what the documentary
explains
oh really because because that's how
they earn more money and that's how they
get a better return
on their on the ad money that
advertisers spend because they want
people that have specific interests
obviously and you can you can narrow
that down when you buy ads on facebook
and twitter
so they want to feed these people this
exact same
content so they can funnel more relevant
ads to them and it keeps them in these
[ __ ] in these single lanes of content
keep something like these echo chambers
right so
basically the the summary i don't want
to ruin it for you but the babies
i'm one of those people that you could
tell me a [ __ ] movie that i really
want to watch yeah you could tell me the
end and how it happens
and i'll be okay i don't give two shits
ever spoil me yeah so like the moral the
moral of the story is just
you know the effect of
these social media companies focusing so
much on their revenue and not being
regulated so it's all strategic it's
like they didn't plan on doing
this they were just doing this to make
money they didn't they didn't plan on
the effect has been it's kept people in
their own little echo chambers
and it's caused the divide that's going
on right now yeah basically everyone
only seeing specific [ __ ] like
[ __ ] the liberal you know oh my gosh
yeah these [ __ ] lib tards what they
call it
[Laughter]
or you know on the on same thing on the
on the opposite spectrum like if you
[ __ ] like guns or
races right exactly yeah and uh
you know basically these companies have
created this
with you know everything and there needs
to be some sort of regulation on it and
it's
it's [ __ ] freaky man yeah oh just man
just think about there was something
that um
happened to justin bieber he was oh he
was accused of uh
rape and um by
some people online they just you know
posted it
and you know he ended up like proving
that
he that he did not you know he's proven
to [ __ ] he ended up suing them
or whatever um but like
you know when that goes to twitter it
[ __ ]
it's out of your control it's out of
your control oh yes and then
and then then you go who the [ __ ]
liable for that
right like twitter you got to be held
accountable for this [ __ ]
like they try to ruin this man's life
on your platform you know right he's
probably spending time and money trying
to disprove yeah trying to just
you know what he has to do you don't
think about that human
you know you don't think about like what
he has to do just to [ __ ]
just because something somebody said
yeah yeah just because of some
and that's the that's the [ __ ] up
thing and they don't care
you know you guys don't work for twitter
do you okay all right i don't know i'm
making sure
yeah i'm sitting here talking [ __ ] about
your company you [ __ ]
no i mean yeah it's so easy to [ __ ]
somebody up like that but yeah
but at the same time i think of this
there's a lot of things
out here in this world you know and i
learned this from henry so it's not from
me
there's a lot of things out there in
this world that
more so set you up for failure than
success
you know why do you think success is so
hard
failure is so easy you know
and you have to make a choice
you know what i mean it it comes down to
being on you that's why
they can get away with it why do you
think these
[ __ ] places and all that [ __ ] can get
away with all this stuff
because you know at the end of the day
it comes down to
to the person's choice well they chose
to
they chose to drink all that you know
they chose to [ __ ]
yeah drink and drive all that we didn't
tell them to do it that way
right you know what i'm saying yeah so
it's like this
so like you know it's always good to
just like
[ __ ] you know watch out yeah take
care of yourself
you know i it's a
moderation moderation yeah yeah you know
what
um yeah what's what's your [ __ ] limit
what's your [ __ ]
you know that's how i was like okay i
don't [ __ ] with twitter [ __ ] facebook
peace out family
yeah dude it's just like it's just like
[ __ ] being addicted to drugs or
alcohol
yeah that [ __ ] scrolling dude yeah
it's like another hit of dopamine just
oh 100 damn yeah like think about the
[ __ ]
just dangerous oh it is like uh
[Music]
you know like the what was that
epidemic uh the [ __ ] opioid epidemic
yeah yeah yeah
you know that's how i lost my brother
really yeah that's how i lost my brother
i've lost quite a few people from that
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah we know a lot of people
you know yeah in florida hard too i'll
hit florida hearthstone
so hard bro [ __ ] yeah damn we got some
[ __ ] horror stories about people we
know
oh yeah yeah and yeah it was like the
way
you know people i knew that was just
dropping
from the [ __ ] it was like [ __ ]
it's crazy you know it's so like yeah
like
it you know all these things yeah they
set you up
for failure but you got to make a
[ __ ] choice
mm-hmm you know what i mean i'm glad i
[ __ ] did yeah we were talking about
who's
talking to a guy here yesterday and
we're talking about like the war on
drugs and
talking about like making all there was
a [ __ ] there's a country i forget which
country it is
but they made all drugs legal and yeah
their crime went down
like you if you're addicted to heroin
you can go to a clinic and they'll shoot
you up with some heroin and that's a
clean needle doctor will give you a
little dose of heroin yeah get your fix
or whatever
now you're not living on the street
robbing and doing whatever you can do to
get your little effects of heroin
diseases really yeah apparently where
the hell is it
that's crazy
[Laughter]
yeah i you know it it is a very
interesting thing you know
like you know especially with like
marijuana it's like [ __ ]
oh yeah come on come on come on
if you can drink and smoke cigarettes
yeah you know yeah
we should be like that's illegal i can't
believe these [ __ ] politicians
aren't campaigning on that heavy harder
or more you know what i mean like
yeah trump or bond be like look i'm
gonna legalize [ __ ]
they would win oh they would [ __ ] win
all you have to do they would win
they would [ __ ] win yeah literally
just yeah just one
exactly you know what [ __ ] they have
to do
yeah here's a stimulus check and some
weed yeah